the San Antonio express-news says City
police are investigating a video that
surfaced online it shows an officer
repeatedly punching a 14 year-old girl
a bystander recorded it last weekend
officers had responded to calls about a
party David Beck knows in San Antonio
with them more on this story David good
morning Gail good morning I'm standing
in the parking lot where the incident
happened that is an event center there
was a key scene Yetta going on a young
girl's birthday party cops respond to a
report that a fight has broken out once
they arrived they alleged that a 14 year
old girl assaulted a police officer but
the girl's family says look she was
trying to help break up the fight and
then someone recorded this on camera the
grainy video captured on Saturday night
appears to show a San Antonio police
officer strike a fourteen-year-old girl
in the face at least one several
officers then appear to forcefully
subdue her you hear the screams of
onlookers the woman seen here in the
white dress is the girl's mother
April Johnson actually played the video
over and over and over again and
actually seeing that I was in arm's
reach of my child ain't got fair death I
just know she was just trying to break
up of coffee she was trying to break up
anything from happening again the
eighth-grade girl whose family says
she's an honor roll student with no
history of violence was arrested and
held in a detention center until Monday
afternoon charged with assaulting of
public officials what we see on the
video is very clear is that this officer
made physical and violent contact with
the face of this fourteen-year-old in a
written statement San Antonio's mayor
Ivy Taylor called the alleged assault a
scuffle saying the video is hard to
watch and to listen to SAPD is now
reviewing body cam video to determine
exactly what happened San Antonio police
have not released any of the footage
body cameras were implemented by the
department last year you can't handle
your job don't do it if you have that
much aggression maybe you should have
called in that day because there's no
point
you hit a 14 year old child you need to
be taken out to shoes the name of the
officer has not been released the police
chief says they are reviewing weather
department policies were followed
charlie that young girl is now out of
the detention center and home with her
mother David thanks